we were watching this great YouTube
video of after Chazz Palminteri and the
video was entitled who to trust in this
business and Chaz had some interesting
takes on it and he jokingly said first
off trust no one and then he said well
above all trust your own gut no your own
intuition to his gut did Chaz's gut tell
him to do in the mix with usher that
emmanuelle chriqui I'm sorry I'm anyone
no he didn't mention that part but um he
also mentioned that in terms of getting
feedback on a film there's kind of two
ways to do this if someone asks for your
feedback and the film is still in the
editing process hmm then it's probably
maybe okay to be a little more truthful
and say you know what I probably could
agree that maybe you could make changes
here there but if the film's already
finished he says pretty much just shake
the person's hand said great job and
then just keep it positive what's your
take on why just know from first hand
that just making a movie is a tremendous
accomplishment in itself and it's a team
sport and no one person can be blamed
everybody wanted to blame Taylor Kitsch
for why John Carter didn't do well at
the box office has nothing to do with
taylor kitsch you know it's it's a
there's a lot of cooks in the kitchen
when it comes to making movie so just
making a movie is it a tremendous
accomplishment in its owner and then to
make a really good movie obviously is an
amazing thing so to have that kind of
foundation to just understand that and
not take anything for granted then you
can have a more out of Mount candid
conversation when it comes to your
opinion about film nobody needs me to
come up to them at their premier or at
their junket nobody needs me to come and
say great job I loved it if I did it
it's just and you see it a lot
out here it's crazy and you have you
know we all have friends who make movies
and you want to support their films even
if you don't like their films because
they're your friend but you have to be
true to yourself and your audience
doesn't care about your relationship
with a director or an actor and I get
that a lot people say to me how can you
be
with an actor and then review their
movie and I always reference the store
my dad told me for one of his interviews
is Michael Caine I guess somebody had
asked Michael Caine your this legendary
actor this Oscar winner your sir michael
caine why are you in one of the sequels
to jaws like how did someone of your
stature and your ability get into the
sequel of jaws is terrible and he said I
have to be honest I haven't seen the
film so I don't know if it's any good or
bad but have you seen the house that I
got from making the movie it's really
nice right so I remember that often when
I interview actors is they're getting
paid it's not all on them there's gonna
be a next movie around the corner and
you stand out more by being the guy who
comes in and says this wasn't really for
me I didn't care for this part of it I
enjoyed this aspect if you can do that
and be honest and true to yourself it
means more when you do tell them that
you like the movie I've formed a nice
working relationship with Shia LaBeouf
over the years and I'll speak candidly
to him about his movies and I'll say
dude this didn't work or I think you
needed to do this well until appreciate
it because for every time I've told him
something that hasn't worked or whatever
there's there's a time when I say hey
this I'm really happy you did a movie
like guide to recognizing your saints
and you push yourself and did something
different with Chazz Palminteri by the
way tying it full circle um but uh I
don't know like certain people he's a
kid who wears his heart on his sleeve
and you can talk to him candidly and
he's he respects it more if you tell
them the truth and if you just say great
job transformers two awesome bro you
know like nobody needs that so oh no I
mean Chaz is in a different position
than I am in a different part of this
business than i am but for someone like
me who's reviewed films over the years i
have to be honest and i have to be
candid there's there's a difference in
somebody's work and making it personal
and you could say you can talk about the
work and you can talk about you know the
film or the choices that were made or
whatever but when it gets nasty and
personal and lowest common
then that's nobody needs that is that
that's where it becomes snarky and no
you see that a lot of times with it
actors have to deal with their public
persona their professional persona and
sometimes you know people are sick of
seeing somebody in the tabloid magazines
so they don't they don't respect the
work they do and you saw with Tom Cruise
when he was kind of at the height of all
that crazy stuff happening and jumping
on the couch and Matt Lauer and the
whole thing people were turned off to
him at the movies and and were quick to
knock his work and not like a film and I
remember mission impossible three came
out and God I think like pretty pretty
bad reviews and didn't do so well at the
box on people are just a little Tom
Cruise overlooked if you go back and
watch those first three mission
impossibles it's probably the best one
out of them philip seymour hoffman's
terrific in it and JJ dozens JJ's first
movie that he directed let's say that's
like a great film but that was just an
interesting time in pop culture and
celebrity and and and then that
somebody's persona kind of dominated
anything they did on screen and you saw
crews kind of take a step back he went
dead lions for lambs with Robert Redford
and in his scenes in it only with Meryl
Streep and it's a supporting role at a
smaller movie and he did you know
Valkyrie which was a an interesting take
on a story with some traditionally you
know talented accomplished British
actors if you will he surrounded himself
a good people seems to be a theme of our
interview and kind of got back on track
you